Let me show you how you can crush a
sales call as an introvert. Okay, let me
give you a script. We're going to use
this formula called P A S. And the first
thing that you want to do when you get
on a sales call is you want to ask them
the problem they are trying to solve.
So, your client, your customer is going
to spew out for as long as you let them
talk and they're going to self-sell
themselves on the problem they have.
Let's say you get on the phone and
you're like, "Hey, what's going on with
your Clavio flows? How are those
performing? Oh my god, they're not set
up properly. You know, sometimes these
campaigns go out and they overlap and
and the coupon codes mess up and we're
not getting the revenue and blah blah
blah." And they're going to start
talking about the problem. As an
introvert, you just sit there and go,
"Oh, okay. Oh man, oh that sucks. Oh
goodness." Right? And you just let them
talk and talk and talk. And then when
they've run out of some words to say,
you agitate
the problem. You ask a follow-up
question that makes this problem so much
worse. Man, how long has it been broken
like that? Oh my god, months. I don't
know, it's just the guy said he'd fix
it, blah blah blah. And how much revenue
do you think you've lost with it broken?
You see what I'm doing? I'm agitating
the problem. Whatever problem they said,
I'm amplifying how much money they lost,
how much time they've lost. Oh my god,
it's been the worst, blah blah blah. And
then you simply offer a solution. And
the last thing you want to do is just
say,
"Would you like some help?" "Uh, yeah,
that would be helpful." They're usually
now susceptible to some help and you can
offer your free audit or you can offer
your service or whatever it is, but this
is them doing talking 80% of the time,
maybe even 90% of the time. So, you as
an introvert literally sell them by
doing nothing, letting them rattle off
their problems, make it bigger, and then
offer a solution. That's it. And if you
missed it,